[Música]
este es el espacio de medio ambiente en
france24 yo soy maría clara calle y les
doy la bienvenida y ya comenzó la cumbre
climática de naciones unidas- la cob 26
esta es la cita más importante para que
los países definan sus compromisos con
el objetivo de limitar el calentamiento
global pero la negociación en la ciudad
de glasgow no es nada fácil porque hay
muchos intereses encontrados para
entender por qué esta cumbre es tan
relevante primero es necesario hablar de
los 15 grados celsius a los que tanto se
refiere esta meta está en el acuerdo de
parís un pacto de 2015 con el que los
países se trazaron el objetivo de que el
mundo no se calentará dos grados
adicionales durante este siglo y en lo
posible que ese incremento no supere los
15 grados hechos aunque la diferencia
aparece poca en los números en la
realidad del planeta cambiaría todo
entre más se caliente la tierra habrá
muchas más olas de calor los huracanes
serán más fuertes y aumentará más el
nivel del mar al punto de poner en
riesgo a cientos de ciudades costeras el
agua potable sería cada más escasa
la urgencia es que ya vamos por mal
camino desde la época preindustrial la
temperatura de la tierra ha aumentado
1,1 grados y la onu cambio climático
estima que incluso si se cumplen los
planes que tienen los gobiernos
actualmente igual se podrían superar los
27 grados adicionales por eso el momento
de actuar es ahora y la cob 26 es el
mejor espacio para trazar metas más
ambiciosas porque es el único espacio
donde se reúnen la mayoría de los
líderes del mundo para tomar acciones
frente al cambio climático así lo
dijeron ellos
esta es nuestra oportunidad para
escribir la historia es nuestra
obligación actuar ahora europa con su
pacto verde no ahorrará esfuerzos para
convertirse en el primer continente que
logre la neutralidad de carbono pero en
esta copa todos tenemos que acelerar
nuestra carrera hacia la neutralidad
aurich un éxito
show de luisito pits nos enfrentamos a
una decisión difícil o detenemos el
cambio climático o él nos detiene a
nosotros
y las brutales en bagdad y ver si es
hora de decir basta basta de dañar la
biodiversidad de matarnos con carbono
basta de tratar a la naturaleza como un
inodoro y hasta de quemar perforar y
minar aún más nuestro camino estamos
cavando nuestras propias tumbas pero el
cambio es urgente porque el ipcc que
reúne a los expertos de cambio climático
del mundo ya advirtió que las emisiones
que contaminan el planeta deben
reducirse a un 45 por ciento para 2030 y
lograr la neutralidad de carbono en el
2050 de lo contrario la temperatura
aumentará y sus consecuencias serán
catastróficas
y aquí viene otro de los términos clave
para entender la cob 26 neutralidad de
carbono esto no significa que los países
eliminen por completo sus
contaminaciones de las fábricas o de la
producción de energía sino que las
reduzcan y las compensan con proyectos
que le ayuden a la atmósfera a absorber
esos gases contaminantes para que al
final la suma de gases sea cero por
ejemplo plantando árboles o
desarrollando tecnologías para capturar
el dióxido de carbono el cómo y cuándo
lograr la neutralidad de carbono es lo
que propone cada país con su
contribución determinada nacional o nds
por sus siglas en inglés que son los
planes con los que cada nación ayudará a
limitar el calentamiento global
pero esta no es una discusión nada fácil
porque hay muchos intereses en juego
muchas de las industrias que mueven la
economía del mundo son las más
contaminantes y las que provocan la
mayor parte de los gases de efecto
invernadero que calientan al planeta de
esos gases el dióxido de carbono y el
metano son los que más contaminan estos
son producidos principalmente por la
explotación de carbón de petróleo y de
gas que hoy son las mayores fuentes de
energía del mundo y las que más daño
provocan la deforestación y la
agricultura a gran escala también son
una fuente importante de emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero
a pesar de que los combustibles fósiles
son los que más contaminan la mayoría de
los líderes mundiales han sido ambiguos
o no han mencionado que acabarán y que
los reemplazarán totalmente por energías
renovables como la eólica o la solar por
eso el gran punto a analizar en la cob
26 es si los mandatarios se comprometen
con planes concretos y más ambiciosos
que los que propusieron en el 2015 para
reducir las emisiones nacionales y
ayudar a limitar el calentamiento global
o si por el contrario sus llamados a una
acción
son sólo de palabra como lo han
criticado activistas ambientales en los
primeros días de la cumbre climática la
novedad fue que india dijo por primera
vez para cuando aspira a lograr la
neutralidad de carbono es un anuncio
esperado porque es el tercer país que
más contamina después de china y eeuu
pero no fue del todo esperanzador porque
puso su límite para 20 años después de
lo que plantea la meta global conectamos
a esta hora con nuestra enviada especial
a glasgow marina colorado ella tiene
todos los detalles de los compromisos
que se propuso india y otros países como
brasil
una de las claves para cumplir con el
objetivo del acuerdo de parís de
mantener el aumento de las temperaturas
actuales por debajo del grado y medio
son las contribuciones determinadas a
nivel nacional es decir los planes de
reducción de emisiones que cada país
tiene que ir actualizando y mejorando
para que sean más ambiciosos cada cinco
años 117 países ya lo han hecho pero tal
y como están esas revisiones las de las
emisiones aumentarían un 16 por ciento
comparado con
2010 en latinoamérica el 75% de los
países han entregado sus planes de
emisiones revisados para esta cop sin
embargo china un país el país más emisor
del mundo no ha entregado ninguna
novedad durante esta cop porque mantiene
su meta de neutralidad de carbono para
el año
2060 uno de los grandes anuncios que
llegó durante esta cop fue de la mano
del primer ministro indio narendra modi
que dijo que su país alcanzará la
neutralidad de carbono en el año 2070 es
decir no emitirá más es contaminantes de
los que es capaz de absorber o capturar
una fecha que al principio generó
bastante estupor porque todavía faltan
50 años para alcanzar ese día sin
embargo analistas y expertos aseguran
que es un gran paso en la lucha contra
el cambio climático
además de qué hacer con los combustibles
fósiles la otra gran discusión tiene que
ver con dinero porque los países más
ricos se comprometieron desde el 2009
que para el 2020 le darían 100 mil
millones de dólares cada año a las
naciones en desarrollo el objetivo es
que con ese dinero ellos puedan
adaptarse al cambio climático y mitigar
sus efectos era una manera de justicia
porque muchos de los países que menos
contaminan son los que más sufren las
consecuencias del calentamiento global
sin embargo la promesa no se cumplió la
ocde rastreo que las naciones
desarrolladas han dado menos de 80 mil
dólares y la gran mayoría son en
préstamos que complican la economía de
los países más pobres la idea de esta
cop 26 es que se establezcan nuevos
compromisos para cumplir con la
financiación que prometiera otro debate
de dinero es el mercado de carbono que
creó el acuerdo de parís la idea es que
un país que no disminuya notablemente
sus emisiones pueda financiar proyectos
en otras naciones que ayuden a reducir
los gases contaminantes pero los
mandatarios ya han intentado ponerle
reglas a ese mercado en dos cumbres
climáticas anteriores y no han podido
muchos esperan que la cob 26 sea el
momento para hacerlo lo que sí ocurrió
durante los primeros días de la cumbre
en glasgow es que hubo compromisos en
dos temas concretos más de 100 países se
comprometieron a parar la deforestación
el acuerdo lo firmaron los países donde
más se talan bosques que son rusia
brasil canadá eeuu e indonesia todos los
firmantes tienen el 85 por ciento de los
bosques del planeta
y también hubo un pacto para reducir las
emisiones de metano que es más potente
que el dióxido de carbono pero que se
desaparece más rápido el problema es que
los tres países que más producen este
gas china rusia e india no se sumaron a
la iniciativa únicamente de estas
naciones son responsables del 34 por
ciento del metano del mundo
marina colorado desde glasgow nos
explica en qué consisten estos pactos
curiosamente dos de los anuncios más
fuertes durante los primeros días de la
cop 26 no estaban dentro de la agenda
oficial más de 100 países productores y
consumidores de productos ligados a la
deforestación como la palma la soya o el
ganado firmaron la declaración global
sobre los bosques y la tierra se
comprometen a frenar y revertir la
deforestación antes del 2030 la
deforestación supone un cuarto de los
gases de efecto invernadero
20.000 millones de dólares serán
dedicados de fondos públicos y privados
a esta misión ha sido bienvenida por
www para la naturaleza que ha recordado
que ahora hay que implementarlo porque
el compromiso no es realmente vinculante
es decir no están obligados a cumplirlo
eeuu indonesia república democrática del
congo china o rusia países con grandes
superficies forestales se han
comprometido a cumplir con este objetivo
sin embargo ha habido otro anuncio
importante con respecto al
a la reducción de los gases metano una
iniciativa de eeuu y la unión europea el
objetivo es reducir el 30 por ciento de
las emisiones con respecto al 2020 antes
de la próxima década el gas metano es
mucho más potente que el dióxido de
carbono del co2 dura 12 años solo entre
comillas en la atmósfera comparado con
los 100 que dura el dióxido de carbono
pero se disipa más rápidamente algo que
hace que su reducción podría ser muy
beneficiosa para reducir el aumento de
las temperaturas y por tanto la
aceleración del calentamiento global y
del cambio climático china rusia e india
países grandes países emisores de metano
no se han puesto de acuerdo para ser
parte de esta iniciativa y en la
reducción de emisiones haría que se
podría reducir las emisiones pero el
aumento de las temperaturas en 0,3
grados antes del año 2040 gracias marina
por el reporte nosotros seguiremos
pendientes de todos los anuncios que se
logren en la cob 20 especialmente
miraremos qué tanto se comprometen a
limitar el calentamiento global los
invitamos a que se conecten de nuevo con
nosotros el 16 de noviembre a las 6 45
de la tarde en ahora bogotá quito lima
tendremos un especial sobre las
conclusiones de esta cumbre climática y
que tanto se logró los espero y nos
vemos en otra ocasión
[Música]